cuál es la situación que vive el líbano
en medio del hartazgo de los jóvenes por
la corrupción de los partidos
tradicionales
bueno tenemos en dos posturas una que
sigue siendo la tradicional es decir
seguir a los partidos políticos de los
que siguieron sus padres y que son los
excombatientes y es como una cuestión de
fidelidad y por otro lado tenemos los
jóvenes que son la mayoría que
participaron en la revolución del 2019
que gracias a esa revolución y después
de esa revolución crearon partidos
políticos se unieron también con adultos
no es solamente un movimiento de jóvenes
pero es todo un movimiento de sangre
nueva sangre fresca que no estaba en
política antes que es lo que el pueblo
está reclamando ellos reclaman sobre
todo un gobierno de tecnócratas es decir
gente que sea profesional y que sea
capaz de
llevar a cabo un cambio no por intereses
personales que es lo que se viene
haciendo hasta ahora es la forma de
gobierno que tiene el líbano que es muy
personalista muy
a lo que fue la guerra de hace 30 años y
que no se pueden despegar de eso porque
tiene mucha gente tiene miedo al cambio
piensa que una nueva generación no es
capaz de afrontar los problemas por los
que pasa el líbano hoy en día ayer en
estos días perdón el líder de gestión de
cita invitaba a los chiítas del sur y
del este especialmente no los invitas
perdón los mandaban a votar a su partido
es gol da es un partido armado que
trabaja opera especialmente en el sur
del líbano contra israel y dice que si
no lo votan a él el iva no va a quedar
desprotegido con israel hay toda una
manipulación acá entonces bueno también
o sea a los chiítas como que los obliga
y después se presentó también en beirut
que es un poco más un mix de religiones
ya con un discurso un poco más pausado
invitando a los cristianos
porque si no nadie va a defender el país
y es una
manipulación discursiva bueno y en este
contexto cuáles son las posibilidades
reales de una transformación social algo
puede nacer de estos comicios
mira así
hay una posibilidad de que entren 13
diputados más o menos entonces
eso es un número
porque digo nada de que esté
completamente dominado por los partidos
tradicionales a una mínima posibilidad
pueden entrar tres se pueden entrar
menos si la gente se agarra las
tradiciones pero si están a por el
cambio si puede haber un mínimo cambio
es decir gente que pueda poner presión
en él en el gobierno desde su banca no
nuevos proyectos nuevas leyes cambio
para es un poco incierto pero si hay
mucho movimiento en el país bueno y qué
tan fuerte puede ser el impacto del
llamado al boicot del ex primer ministro
saad hariri la representatividad del
partido hezbollah podría aumentar
mira el sace y claramente representa a
los sunitas y ni siquiera a los sunitas
ni siquiera a todos los sunitas
entonces si él le está llamando
boicotear las elecciones no tiene
sentido o sea la gente ya ha votado de
hecho el domingo pasado hubo elecciones
en el mundo entero para el líbano de los
libaneses que se han inscrito para votar
una concurrencia a un 60 por ciento de
los inscritos que es bastante ya que no
no es usual es la segunda vez que es un
voto así desde el exterior
entonces es que salga y esté llamando a
boicotear las elecciones no tiene mucho
sentido quizás los partisanos los pelos
los seguidores de él sí puedan ponerse
al frente a las urnas o puedan no ir a
votar pero le están dejando el paso a
los que vayan a votar